bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoints
l'émission qui revient sur l'actualité
iconomique locale on commence tout de
suite avec les grandes lignes la
circulation des bus reprend peu à peu
sur Versailles et dans les villes
alentours le blocage du dépôt a dû être
stoppé suite à une décision de justice à
l'approche des élections européennes
nous avons cherché à savoir comment
l'Union européenne et des les
entreprises notamment les PME les
réponses dans notre dossier de la
semaine
et puis nous parlerons de la
irréputation avec nos invités nous
recevons sur ce plateau Georges
fulgencio bonsoir vous êtes dirigeants
d'ecovie bio face à vous où se trouve
Emmanuel Pitot bonsoir dirigeante du
nouvel du nouvel air pardon de vous
accompagner toutes deux les entreprises
dans leur développement sur la toile
nous verrons ça dans un instant est-ce
que la présence sur le web est
indispensable notamment et par quel
biais s'y prendre mais avant cela on
passe à l'actualité économique de la
semaine
lever du piquet de grève au dépôt de bus
de Versailles à l'entreprise Fébus hier
le tribunal acteur ordonné l'arrêt du
blocage mis en place depuis le 12 mai
depuis le service de bus de Versailles
était complètement à l'arrêt les
grévistes réclament notamment une
augmentation salariale de 5% aujourd'hui
les représentants syndicaux et la
direction ont entamé le dialogue selon
les grévistes 15% du trafic aurait
repris
d'après une étude relevée mardi par le
groupe France industriel emploi et
l'agence de ressources humaines Kurt
Salmon les créations d'emplois ont chuté
de 18% 2013 le secteur le plus touché
les services ou la baisse atteint les
39,5% la région qui s'en sort le mieux
reste l'Île-de-France et grâce notamment
à l'industrie aéronautique bien présente
dans les Yvelines
de nouvelles négociations débutées sur
le financement du nouveau Grand Paris le
Medef a saisi cette occasion pour faire
entendre sa voix l'organisation
patronale souhaite la poursuite du
projet d'amélioration du transport
urbain elle craint que les budgets
soient limités à cause des baisses de
subventions des collectivités
territoriales si des choix sont à
prendre le Medef souhaite accès en
priorité sur la desserte des aéroports
et des pôles majeurs de développement
comme la défense où nous concernant le
plateau de Saclay ainsi que sur le
désenclavement de l'Est parisien
une comptine qui propose des fruits et
légumes frais des petits plats cuisinés
comme à la maison
utopique c'est en tout cas ce que tente
de mettre en place petit à petit la
cantine municipale de Trappes une
initiative que félicite la filière des
fruits et légumes frais ce secteur
devrait progresser d'ici les années à
venir des images de jonathaniel
mon G5 fruits et légumes par jour une
recommandation connue aujourd'hui de
tous et pourtant les Français de moins
de 35 ans mangent 2,5 fois moins de
produits frais que les plus de 65 ans le
public le plus dur à convaincre les
enfants j'aime bien les carottes et la
salade
après le reste
une perte financière pour la filière et
un risque certain pour la santé attrape
27% des enfants sont touchés par
l'obésité 12 points de plus que la
moyenne nationale alors depuis deux ans
les services municipaux tentent de faire
bouger les choses cette cantine
municipale gère l'ensemble des repas
distribués en milieu scolaire 315000
couverts à l'année la consommation de
produits frais il y a progressé de 20%
au menu des lasagnes des purées et des
potages faits maison on utilise des
produits qui sont transformés mes frais
alors qu'avant on produit des produits
surgelés où on prenait des produits en
boîte et donc tout ça c'est l'évolution
de nos métiers et progressivement on est
passé vers des produits qui sont qui
vont de plus en plus frais avec le moins
d'un train possible c'est l'eau
interfell les fruits et légumes frais
représentent 7,5% des achats
alimentaires des restaurateurs soit 1,2
milliards d'euros un enjeu indéniable de
la restauration hors domicile pour
développer ce secteur il faut viser la
jeune génération les fruits et légumes
aujourd'hui sont au cœur d'un central de
consommation et que c'est bien la classe
d'âge dans lequel se forge les habitudes
de consommation qui nous intéresse et
bien sûr la mise en oeuvre des des
produits et déterminants dans leur
consommation de demain mais difficile de
cuisiner comme à la maison en continu
scolaire cet agent prépare la compote de
demain 1000 pommes pelées pour les
centres aérés de mercredi soit 4 heures
de travail un coup de main d'oeuvre
supplémentaire pour y remédier la ville
envisage d'externaliser les tâches de
découpe à les actes de Trappes ou les
coûts salariés sont plus faibles autre
difficulté faire en sorte que les
enfants dépassent leur appréhension et
pour cela il faut être imaginatif pour
faire manger du chou rouge on fait le
concours de celui qui a la langue la
plus rouge et là ça incite les enfants à
avoir la langue rouge et à consommer du
chou rouge voilà typique de ce genre
d'exemple de service et formation sont
prévues pour le personnel de service un
concours du meilleur menu est également
organisé chaque année Chinese et l'une
des cinq lauréates sa sélection sera
cuisinée jeudi au programme melon ou
encore saumon sauce citron et coriandre
et mais parce que j'aimais bien et
j'avais plein de choses en tête les
mentalités commencent à évoluer attrape
le budget dédié à la restauration
collective représente plus de 3 millions
d'euros chaque année
on connaît les bienfaits du sport pour
la santé mais en entreprise les
activités sportives ont encore bien
d'autres attraits comme par exemple
favoriser l'esprit d'équipe
démonstration à la base de loisirs de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines ou s'est
déroulé samedi dernier l'accouple
nationale des entreprises
samedi dernier c'est sous le soleil que
ses compétiteurs s'affrontaient sur
l'eau mais qu'ils soient en laser ou en
catamaran il ne défendait pas leur club
mais leur entreprise ici pas de victoire
individuelles la Fédération Française de
Voile proposer une des rares
compétitions en équipe la règle c'est
celui qui arrive dernier sur les quatre
bateaux fait perdre son équipe donc
celui qui est devant va ralentir
l'équipe adverse pour faciliter le
travail de son coéquipier pour éviter
que effectivement sont coéquipiers soit
dernier quoi c'est vraiment l'objectif
dans les compétitions traditionnelles
ces deux collègues sont concurrents
quand on leur a proposé de faire équipe
pour leur société ils n'ont pas hésité
c'est une très belle compétition annuel
et on est là aussi pour représenter
notre entreprise et puis le fait de
naviguer en équipe ça donne des
tactiques et des stratégies différentes
qui est extrêmement intéressantes en
matière de voile pour gagner il faut par
exemple bloquer l'adversaire comme nous
l'explique cet ancien habitué des
podiums c'est très délicat parce que il
faut ralentir mais sans faire de fautes
et donc comme il y a un jury sur l'eau
qui est tout le jury vous siffle et à ce
moment là le la bonne tactique peut se
révéler une très mauvaise tactique et
encore pire que de ne rien faire ok de
litige les concerné conteste
le jury sur l'eau valide ou non la faute
pour la Fédération Française de Voile
organisatrice de l'événement ce type de
compétition permet d'attirer de nouveaux
adhérents mais aussi de véhiculer des
valeurs indispensables au travail en
entreprise c'est tout ce que peut
apporter le sport dans l'entreprise
c'est-à-dire la cohésion sociale
c'est-à-dire l'activité de mieux se
connaître dans l'entreprise au total 42
participants naviguaient sous les
couleurs de leur société la victoire est
revenue aux entreprises Soraya finance
et Thalès
attention il ne vous reste plus que
quelques jours pour postuler pour le
concours talent des cités pour ceux qui
n'en n'auraient pas encore entendu
parler il s'agit d'un concours visant à
récompenser des créateurs d'entreprises
ou des porteurs de projets
entrepreneuriaux ou associatifs pour y
participer de conditions que le projet
ou l'entreprise soit implantée dans un
quartier prioritaire de la politique de
la ville comme une zone urbaine sensible
par exemple ou une zone franche et
deuxième condition être accompagnée par
un organisme d'aide à la création
d'entreprises telles que le réseau BGE
ou une chambre de commerce on écoute
Céline Leroux conseillère et formatrice
à la BGE la structure qui organise ce
concours
le créateur par son parcours mais aussi
l'activité généralement qui est assez
pérenne vu qu'elle a déjà quelques
années derrière elle ça peut être
l'innovation voilà peut avoir plusieurs
critères mais on met pour talendicité
davantage le créateur en avant son
initiative son projet ses démarches à
aller jusqu'au bout de ses projets ce
sont des créateurs généralement qui sont
dans des zones quand même assez
difficile
dans des quartiers assez difficiles pour
s'en sortir donc du coup bah c'est des
créateurs qui ont une motivation et qui
vont généralement jusqu'au bout de leurs
projets et donc qui arrive à créer des
activités des emplois donc c'est surtout
ça qu'on veut mettre en avant que bah
créateur quel que soit d'où il vient
puisse réussir dans la vie et une
victoire au niveau régional permet
d'obtenir des dotations entre 1000 et
2000 euros un suivi et une qualification
pour le championnat national les deux
grands gagnants tiendront 7000 euros et
une campagne de publicité sur les
chaînes nationales pour y participer
rendez-vous sur le site talent des
cités.fr et on passe maintenant à
l'entretien sur la réputation
et donc pour cet entretien nous recevons
Georges fulgencio bonsoir comme je
disais donc du coup en introduction vous
êtes dirigeant déco Vivio nous recevons
également Emmanuel Peto dirigeant du
nouvel air alors par vos activités vous
accompagner les entrepreneurs ou les
entreprises dans leur stratégie web pour
commencer tout simplement qu'est-ce que
la réputation finalement
c'est l'équivalent de la réputation et
avec les avis que l'on peut voir sur le
web sur la toile comme vous le disiez
donc tout ce qui va parler d'une
personne ou d'une entreprise mais
uniquement sur internet c'est ça
l'irréputations alors vous êtes arrivés
finalement dans ce secteur par des biais
différents ce n'était pas forcément
votre formation première alors on va
commencer avec vous qu'est-ce qui vous a
guidé dans cette voie finalement en fait
j'ai travaillé dans le commercial
pendant 13 ans et puis j'ai souhaité me
lancer et apporter mon expertise aux
entreprises et en fait le web est devenu
tellement important que j'en ai fait ma
spécialité donc toujours la prospection
mais grâce au web et grâce aux réseaux
sociaux c'est quelque chose que vous
avez découvert finalement en quittant
votre premier métier où vous l'exercice
est déjà auparavant le web je
connaissais je vais travailler deux ans
dans une start-up et les réseaux sociaux
commençaient à peine c'était en 2007
donc il a fallu que le temps passe pour
que les personnes se disent le site
c'est on en a besoin et ensuite on est
passé à la phase ou d'accord les réseaux
sociaux peut-être qu'il va falloir s'y
mettre
de la même façon éco-vivio à la base ce
n'est pas forcément une société
uniquement portée sur les web alors
comment expliquer ce développement
écoutez moi je suis parti d'une
expérience avec une base métier qui est
celui du bâtiment et puis en fait vision
de business où on allait effectivement
dans le bâtiment travailler de plus en
plus en réseau donc déjà la base c'était
travaillé en réseau dit physique et puis
très rapidement par rapport aux réunions
que je menais il y a eu effectivement la
volonté de mettre un réseau social en
ligne donc l'aboutissement de ces
réunions a mener à ce qu'on puisse
mettre un réseau social sur l'habitat
responsable du coup aujourd'hui vous
accompagnez les entreprises de ce
secteur oui dans leur stratégie web
exactement tout à fait un moment donné
donc nous avons mis un réseau social sur
l'habitat responsable pour les acteurs à
la fois particulier et professionnels on
a aussi un magazine web qui apporte du
contenu et il a fallu très rapidement on
s'est posé la question mettre une
stratégie en place après avoir testé
quelques quelques stratégies on s'est
dit qu'en fait il était vraiment
judicieux d'accompagner des
professionnels dans leur développement
et surtout dans le web alors est-ce que
aujourd'hui avoir une stratégie web être
présent sur la toile c'est indispensable
pour n'importe quelle société c'est
indispensable parce que c'est la
première chose que les personnes font
aller sur Google vérifier ce que
l'entreprise a publié rien que le site
internet mais aussi ce que donne
d'autres personnes peuvent en dire donc
même si soi-même on estime que la
société fonctionne grâce au bouche à
oreille donc on n'a pas besoin de
chercher des clients sur Internet c'est
une mauvaise approche parce que un tas
de personnes va d'abord aller voir sur
internet qui se raconte sur une société
avant même de l'appeler vous avez la
même vision Emmanuel a parfaitement
raison c'est un vrai phénomène de
société aujourd'hui un réflexe qui est
très simple je vais sur un moteur de
recherche essentiellement google et je
vais rechercher par rapport à des mots
clés une entreprise un besoin une
attente et donc ça se passe sur le web
selon les secteurs le besoin est quand
même différent
j'ai fait une intervention à la Chambre
de commerce de Caen il y avait un
électricien qui disait moi j'ai pas
besoin de ça les gens m'appellent parce
que on leur a parlé de moi et en direct
on a fait le test on est allé sur Google
on a tapé le nom de sa société comme il
n'avait rien sur Internet bah forcément
Google remplit avec d'autres choses donc
c'était des annuaires d'électricien il y
avait tous ses concurrents juste à côté
de lui qui avait peut-être fait plus
d'efforts que lui pour donner voilà du
contenu et de la richesse à l'image de
l'entreprise donc tous les secteurs
d'activités sont concernés
des approches différentes des vous
définissez disons des besoins dans la
stratégie web en fonction de chaque
entreprise oui effectivement il est
préférable de bien analyser son
environnement c'est-à-dire que avant de
se lancer sur les réseaux sociaux il y a
un travail en amont qui est nécessaire
c'est de savoir quel est son son
environnement commençons en entreprise
gravie dans cet environnement et comment
je mets une stratégie en place ça je
pense que c'est assez important parce
que se lancer sur les réseaux sociaux
sans une véritable stratégie ça peut
être dangereux donc vaut mieux
effectivement en amont bien réfléchi à
ses besoins et aussi de pouvoir mettre
des objectifs en place
l'idée finalement d'être présent sur la
toile ce n'est pas forcément que créer
son site bien évidemment non parce que
de toute façon pour reprendre l'exemple
de Google il y a effectivement d'autres
moteurs de recherche mais il a une
écrasante majorité des requêtes Google
va remplir les pages avec quelque chose
donc si c'est pas l'entreprise qui a
publié des pages des sites des blogs des
articles des plaquettes Google trouvera
autre chose pour remplir cette page que
l'entreprise n'aura pas forcément
maîtrisé donc ce sera pas forcément dans
le sens qu'elle le souhaite donc c'est
pour ça que c'est important de savoir de
faire de la veille savoir ce qui se
raconte sur internet à son sujet mais
aussi de publier des des articles des
des
la maquette des vidéos des photos pour
enrichir justement cette irréputation et
la maîtriser alors justement on parle de
faire une veille comment finalement
contrer la mauvaise réputation sur la
toile
comment contrer la mauvaise réputation
avant tout c'est ce que je disais au
préalable vaut mieux déjà penser à sa
propre stade sa stratégie et mettre une
bonne irréputation en place la contrée
après il y a de nombreux de nombreuses
possibilités
justement en faisant une veille
régulière savoir ce qui se passe par
rapport à son entreprise ou proprement à
soi parler il est important de savoir ce
qui se passe sur sur la toile sur soi et
ensuite de prendre du recul je pense
jamais se précipiter et répondre très
directement les règles du community
manager ce métier implique qu'on doit
prendre du recul et ensuite trouver la
bonne stratégie de communication
répondre et il y a de nombreux outils
pour pouvoir contrer une mauvaise
irréputation
alors à noter tout de même vous allez
organiser une formation prochainement à
la Cité des métiers
qui cette fois ne sera pas ouverte
seulement aux entrepreneurs mais
également à des demandeurs d'emploi
finalement la réputation ça concerne
tout le monde sur ma chaîne emploi et
oui effectivement tout à fait on a
maintenant du retour par rapport à ces
formations aux demandeurs d'emploi
c'est essentiel parce que il se passe
tellement de choses sur la toile et en
plus l'objectif du demandeur d'emploi
c'est bien évidemment de trouver un
emploi et là c'est un outil vraiment
extrêmement pertinent qui permet de
trouver un emploi donc avec la Cité des
Métiers à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines on a
décidé de mettre des formations on a
beaucoup demandeurs d'emploi qui
viennent et c'est très intéressant de
faire ces formations il y a beaucoup
d'interactions c'est très vivant et
souvent les gens arrivent avec des
appréhensions et au fur et à mesure on
va lever toutes ces appréhensions parce
qu'il y en a de nombreuses et les
réseaux sociaux je pense que c'est un
véritable phénomène de société donc il y
a plein d'interactions qui se passent
dans cette formation
pour ceux qui seraient intéressés
rendez-vous donc à la Cité des Métiers
ce sera mardi prochain exactement tout à
fait rendez-vous à la Cité des Métiers
le 27 mai à 10h30 2h de formation pour
pouvoir justement vivre les réseaux
sociaux et surtout atteindre son
objectif qui est de trouver un emploi
très bien merci beaucoup à tous les deux
d'être d'avoir été présent sur notre
plateau merci et on passe maintenant au
dossier
les élections européennes approchent à
grands pas l'occasion pour nous de
s'intéresser à ce que ludion européenne
apporte aux entreprises et notamment aux
petites structures de nombreuses aides
existent mais il est parfois difficile
de s'y retrouver des cryptages avec
notre dossier de la semaine réalisé avec
Patrick Jacques de Dixmude Yolaine
Torres et Romain russepili
agro-ouvre cette ferme est une
institution ou presque la ferme de
Moisan appartient à la famille winocourt
depuis la fin du 19e siècle comme son
arrière-grand-père Marc est agriculteur
depuis 1984 il y cultive du blé du colza
et du maïs une activité série-alière à
la rentabilité aléatoire j'ai assez vite
pris conscience que les aides de
Bruxelles la fameuse pack allait tout
doucement se réduire comme une peau de
chagrin et effectivement on se rend
compte que les aides sont en train de
fondre tout doucement donc j'ai cherché
à diversifier donc nous produisons nos
blé en agriculture raisonnée donc on a
une certification agriculture raisonnée
et donc j'ai décidé de monter une
meunerie sur meule de pierre donc
écraser mes propres blés faire ma propre
farine qui est une farine semi complète
et je travaille avec mes deux fils dont
un a fait une école hôtelière et une
formation en boulangerie l'autre a fait
une école de commerce
et de la commercialisation et nous
tenons toute la chaîne on fait la farine
on a à côté notre fournil on fait notre
pain et on commercialise localement et
on vient d'ouvrir une boutique à Paris
dans le 17e arrondissement se
diversifier pour perdurer mais pour cela
rapidement il a fallu investir pour
payer un cabinet d'ingénierie agricole
et du nouveau matériel montant pour
rénover la meunerie 130 000 euros Mark
s’est alors tourné vers la chambre
d'agriculture ensemble ils ont effectué
une demande de subvention collectivité
territoriale l'Union européenne y a
répondu favorablement avec les conseils
régional et général elle lui a accordé
une aide à hauteur de 30% de son
investissement
c'est du matériel c'est assez technique
il y a des études à faire on fait pas
juste ça comme ça en écrasant du blé
c'est un tout petit peu plus compliqué
là sont des aides que j'ai obtenu pour
investir et pour avoir un outil de
production
pour créer des emplois puisqu'on a
maintenant sur l'exploitation cet emploi
et on espère bien continuer à se
développer au départ la famille
winocourt n'avait que cette meule de
pierre et se tamiseur acheté d'occasion
le financement il est très concret ce
sont ces deux petites meules qui sont
des bol de Pierre des silos de stockage
pour nos céréales et surtout ce qu'on
appelle la transfert pneumatique
c'est-à-dire que la farine est
transportée sous pression d'air une
meilleure qualité de travail pour les
salariés et un système plus rapide la
production de farine à tripler seul
point négatif il a fallu avancer
l'argent impossible sans une trésorerie
solide l'Union européenne est ainsi le
milieu agricole à travers des
financements du fait Ader le Fond
Européen agricole pour le développement
rural mais il existe d'autres fonds
districts avec des budgets plus
conséquents
pour les Fonds structurels il y a deux
grands types de fonds en France le FEDER
le Fonds européen de développement
régional le FSE le Fond Social Européen
c'est sur le même principe c'est-à-dire
une programmation de 7 ans un programme
de travail qui est proposé par les
acteurs locaux
acceptés par la Commission européenne et
ensuite qui va établir les priorités
d'attribution des fonds et les petites
entreprises sont là aussi concernées
pour chaque fond sollicité il faut
répondre à un certain nombre de critères
ils peuvent concerner la taille de
l'entreprise ses partenariats ou encore
le type de secteur au-delà de ces fonds
structurelles l'Union européenne aide
les PME à travers des aides directes
pour en bénéficier les entreprises
doivent postuler auprès de la Commission
européenne via des appels à projets et
selon un calendrier défini les
programmes les plus importants
concernent les secteurs de
l'environnement de l'audiovisuel de
l'aide à la formation mais surtout les
projets de recherche et d'innovation sur
la période précédente donc 2007 2013 sur
l'ensemble de la France
c'est près de 2 milliards
qui ont été attribués aux participants
français donc là PME groupe centre de
recherche donc tout type de d'acteurs
confondus et sont sur cette enveloppe de
2000 milliards c'est plus de 375
millions qui ont été alloués à des PME
française au Jardin de Cocagne à
Magny-les-Hameaux on ne lis pas sur la
recherche et le développement mais sur
l'insertion et l'Union européenne
encourage dans une moindre mesure ces
types d'entreprise ici chaque année 40
personnes éloignées de l'emploi sont
recrutés comme jardiniers le but les
former et les aider à retrouver un poste
pérenne 23000 euros concrètement donc
chaque année qui correspondait au
financement de la personne qui
accompagnait nos jardiniers les Jardins
de Cocagne ont reçu une subvention de
2010 à 2013 via le Fond Social Européen
un des fonds structurels le salaire de
Virginie Mabille est chargé d'insertion
ne pèse pas sur le budget des jardins
grâce à son travail le taux de retour à
l'emploi à grimper de 30 52%
par rapport à ce poste sachant qu'une
personne qu'on accompagne ici ces
personnes qui savent généralement qu'on
discuter par rapport à lecture à
l'écriture la compréhension des papiers
donc il faut vraiment une personne pour
les accompagner et une personne pour les
aider aussi dans le recherche d'emploi
la subvention s'est arrêtée fin 2013 et
malheureusement à ingérard n'a pas
réussi à obtenir un renouvellement de
ses aides pour cette année il devra
trouver des financements privés mais les
entreprises sont assez frileuses à
investir dans des budgets de
fonctionnement peu visible et donc peu
rentable d'un point de vue communication
le chantier d'insertion espère que la
situation se débloquera pour 2015 elle
prévoit de monter un nouveau dossier
avec l'aide du pli le plan local
d'insertion économique car pour une
petite entreprise les démarches sont
souvent laborieuses est un dossier très
compliqué et ils font des professionnels
pour nous aider donc c'est un dossier
très administratif avec beaucoup de
statistiques beaucoup de demandes liées
au projet aussi qui va être très précis
sachant qu'après on pas juger sur les
résultats par rapport au projet pour
contrer ces difficultés l'Union
européenne a mis en place des aides non
financières indirectes qui vont plutôt
être des personnes qui vont les aider à
décrocher ces subventions pour leurs
activités donc là typiquement le Réseau
Entreprises Europe pour l'Île-de-France
et une trentaine de personnes qui sont
qui sont là pour accompagner les
entreprises et les aider à décrypter
tous les programmes tous les prérequis
les textes qui changent et leur éviter
ce travail d'analyse pour déposer un
projet Lauréline Renaud fait partie de
ce réseau entreprises Europe appelée
plus communément en elle répond aux
demandes et interrogations des
entreprises de tous secteurs un service
gratuit en plus d'une aide
administrative et juridique la structure
permet de trouver des partenaires
européens notamment via l'organisation
de convention d'affaires depuis sa
création en 2008 en a accompagné 4000
entreprises d'Île-de-France et de Région
Centre enfin l'Union européenne propose
un quatrième type d'aide auprès
d'institutions financières ces
intermédiaires proposent alors de
meilleurs conditions bancaires comme par
exemple des taux d'emprunt réduits
l'Union européenne vient donc épauler
les entreprises et les petites
structures ont droit à leur part du
gâteau le but est clairement affiché
quel crée de la richesse avec la mise
sur le marché de nouveaux produits ou de
nouveaux services et de l'emploi en
Europe
et on finit avec l'agenda si vous
souhaitez vous renseigner sur la
formation en alternance rendez-vous
mardi 27 mai à la Cité des Métiers à
Trappes de 14 à 17h vous y découvrirez
ce que signifie le contrat
d'apprentissage les métiers concernés ou
encore les établissements de formation
et c'est la fin de ce filetco merci de
nous avoir suivis on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine très bonne soirée à
vous